it influenced the performance more than
I anticipated it to do so that makes
sense once once all of that makeup went
on people reacted and responded to me
differently on set and and I wasn't
anticipating that I didn't necessarily
think that that would help inform
anything but it did because people
naturally wanted to be separate for me
and I was off-putting and so organically
I just kind of stayed in character
because I didn't really have any choice
because no one wanted to talk to me and
in terms of in terms of just the the
technical aspect of it there was I was
never aware of it I was never conscious
of of damaging it or or you know that
would that was it just felt like it was
a part of who I was at that point thank
you gentlemen here yeah I question is a
funaga vote and soft messages how much
did the pumpkin and he was skinned when
you're filming and will he shake up when
he finished a lot and know it and it's
something that I still think about um
the whole experience what I felt like we
as a group went to Pittsburgh to film
this and without sounding too
pretentious I feel like we all
disappeared for a while and and then a
few months later we all emerged from
this experience together and and I don't
think it was so much a matter of shaking
it off I think it I still talk to
Channing and Mark about the experience
and it's very present within all of us I
think we all felt there was a great
responsibility to the people involved
and to Bennett it's just to the story
into the world so I
don't think that that has left any of us
um maybe it's not something that I think
about every hour but it's it's very
present on because I feel like we it was
immersive and and we we all took it very
seriously thank you there's a gentleman
yes this gentleman here and then the
gentleman way at the back yeah you say
it's a similar I don't know how much we
made makeup was exaggerated or how moral
it was to be possible but that week Oh
velocities seemed to me like the
American about conserving personify and
I was wondering whether there was this
undercurrent intentionally placed in the
film regarding how America version of
the last 12 hours usually sort of tries
to fall in certain aspects of sports
especially in the Olympics where America
is a top power was that like an issue in
New Age day one when dragons grip yeah
part of what attracted me to the story
was that it was a true story and yet it
had an allegorical quality to it you
know it had a metaphorical qualities and
in a way that is almost too perfect
there's so many things that just
coincided with what one might have
written had one approach this as a
fictional exercise from the beginning
including what you pointed out but the
the nose is is awfully close to a
replica the irony that he referred to
himself as the Golden Eagle of America
in speech in writing
on you know his jerseys on his trophies
is comical and allegorical but many many
many elements I thought of the story is
naturally fulfilled that same kind of
thing you know like within this tiny
little weird story of these three men
are big themes like of wealth and class
and entitlement and exceptionalism and
all like that but as a film you know I
was attracted to that you acknowledge
that it's there but then put that aside
and and not try to make a statement or
have any kind of conclusion about these
things but examine these dynamics at
work where you you have a person doing
what perhaps is a trend you know in a
society that has such disparity in
classes and things like that
you